on peut dire poli que l'art contemporain
en sologne finalement c'est toute une
histoire depuis quelques jours vous le
disiez une quinzaine de communes des
petits villages de manière générale pour
la plupart accueille des sculptures
monumentales alors en acier en bois ou
en métal et l'objectif passe et houssam
c'est de mettre du beau partout y
compris dans des territoires ruraux que
le bold finalement ne soit pas réservée
à une élite regarder ça se présente
comme un parcours presque comme un jeu
de piste à travers la sologne premier
arrêt a évolué marron petit bourg de 700
habitants c'est un drôle d'objet en
acier qui atterrit près des glisses la
suite conique numéro 3 de gila père
alors forcément dans ce petit village
peu habitué à l'art contemporain
on a jasé c'est l'étonnement
l'étonnement entre ses oeuvres jeudi
globalement moderne et un patrimoine
ancien et la confrontation des deux îles
et interpelle qu'est ce qu'il a voulu
montrer et c'est majeur et c'est ce qui
est intéressant c'est un peu cette
provocation
voilà et leur dire que les offres ce
n'est pas fait que pour des
intellectuels
nous apportons aux solognot des oeuvres
qui n'ont peut-être pas l'habitude de
rencontrer parce que ils ne vont pas au
musée parce que ils n'en ont ni
l'opportunité lille ni l'envi là on leur
apporte sur un plateau
et au détour d'une place en contrebas
d'un pont à l'ombre d'un cas que thouars
leur oeil est attiré par une oeuvre et
ça va déclencher une émotion bien sûr
mais aussi des dialogues
et ça fait parler les gens favorisés
l'émotion et les changes c'est aussi le
credo de ce sculpteur tourangeau lionel
ton d'assez bien que son travail suscite
des émotions contradictoires
ce qui n'est pas pour lui déplaire
autant il ya des gens qui vont voir
quelque chose de tellement noir qui vont
vraiment ils vont être limite choqué
alors que d'autres vont en rire et vont
trouver ça juste comique et donc j'aime
ce c'est les réactions qui peuvent être
très variées des gens donc les douelles
terrain glissant c'est ouais c'est
côtoyer les choses que entre l'humour et
le des choses plus sombres quoi un
parcours où ajoute piste en épousant
l'art contemporain la sologne nous
surprend autrement pour soi moigne de
sauce alors vous êtes sculpteur on vous
doit les deux oeuvres qui sont juste
derrière nous le grand pêcheur sur
échasses et le grand badge alors
pourquoi avoir accepté de participer à
cette biennale d'art contemporain
sachant que c'est quand même une
première propos mais c'est une première
pour vous pourquoi avoir dit oui alors
la première pour la biennale en sologne
oui pour les biennales en général non
puisque j'ai fait déjà d'autres biennale
c'est toujours un honneur et une joie de
pouvoir partager avec les autres son
propre travail donc c'est ça n'est pas
ce n'est pas un refus qui qui est un qui
est à la mise mais au contraire c'est
important justement que l'art
contemporain un petit peu difficile
parfois et partout dans des territoires
ruraux avec la désertification que ce ne
soit pas comme je le disais réservé à
une élite
vous êtes sensible à ça a beaucoup et
parce que ce qui est toujours important
c'est ce qui nous motive c'est à dire
l'émotion et on a envie de faire
partager notre émotion avec tous les
publics bien sûr alors justement d'où
vous vient votre inspiration
vous dites chacune de mes sculptures à
son histoire qu'il s'agisse du souvenir
d'un moment où d'une scène imaginaire
c'est important ça ouais c'est à dire
que ça peut être les voyages que j'ai pu
faire ou alors des images interne que
j'ai une sorte d'icône que j'ai envie de
retranscrire et ensuite n'est l'oeuvre
tout doucement par maturation et puis
ensuite en gestation à l'atelier et tout
doucement tout le processus de création
alors c'est que vous n'avez pas toujours
était sculpteur vous avez fait du
marketing vous avez même commencé votre
carrière
là dedans ça vous épanouissez pas alors
ses couplets trilogy effectivement mais
quand j'ai touché la terre c'était une
révélation total donc c'était voilà les
choses se sont avérées simplement comme
un grand fil conducteur est le chemin
était là ok bah écoutez si si les
téléspectateurs veulent vous retrouvez
nous sommes ici dans un endroit
magnifique au château du moulin là c'est
sûr crâne et les oeuvres sont sont
visibles partout dans la sologne jusqu'à
mi septembre
allez-y ça vaut vraiment le coup